you
[Music]
I'll talk a little bit about second
measuring what we do there in a little
bit but I'm gonna jump right into it so
this talk is kind of in the area of
business analysis it's all about kind of
what happens when you stop thinking
about business results as being a flow
of dollars I just and start thinking
about them as being flows of dollars
that are attached to customers and
analyzing those customers directly and
it's kind of about some some non-obvious
things that happen when you analyze your
data in that way and some some tools
which you can't have kind of evolved
over time for dealing with them as an
outline it's it's gonna be about the
models but we're gonna sort of first set
up the framework
second of all through a little bit of
data to get some some intuition about
about these models and then we're going
to talk through the models and then look
at some more results and if you if you
are interested in sort of following
along don't worry I'll put will post
these slides up on my github which is
github.com /b 11 Z because my name is be
followed by eleven letters followed by Z
so to start with we need to kind of
frame the questions we want to ask and
so caveat here is that this is myself as
a data scientist and former software
engineer presenting on corporate finance
basics so it's going to get a little
weird but this is kind of the smallest
bit of domain knowledge that we're gonna
need to make sure that we're answering
and asking and answering the right
questions so I think this kind of starts
with like asking the question of what
happens when you set the unit of
analysis to be a customer and we're
gonna talk through kind of the
accountants perspective on that and so
you start thinking about all the cash
flows that are associated with that
customer so when they spend with you you
see their purchases those come to come
to you as revenue you're spending money
to buy or build the the things that
you're selling and that's referred to as
cost of goods sold more holistically
than that you're gonna think about all
the costs that are associated associated
with serving that customer so those are
called very variable cost in accounting
this is like everything that scales up
as your customer count scales
and maybe the final one is that you're
also spending money upfront to find
these customers so you're spending on
marketing or something like that that's
referred to as customer acquisition cost
so you kind of you spend that you find
how much you spend on marketing they'll
take that cost you'll divide it by the
number of customers that you manage to
find and then you'll sort of a portion
that cost to each of those customers and
so this is called customer acquisition
cost or if you want to sound cool you
can call it CAC so this is how I kind of
think of that in platform this is just
you know bar chart where the y-axis is
positive if money is coming into the
company and negative if money is coming
out of a company and so you've got the
revenue in red then everything you're
spending on that customer in below and
this is how I think about it but I'm not
really crazy about this plot because you
can't see much so maybe here's a
different way of looking at that this is
plotted as a waterfall so this just
means that the y-axis is not a
cumulative sum and we can see things
ticking up if the cash is coming in and
things sticking down is if cash is going
out to the business so um with that way
of kind of seeing things I want to
define this term of customer lifetime
value to do that we're going to need to
add something and we're going to need to
remove something from that chart so the
thing that we're gonna have to add is
this concept called net present value or
discounting which we I'm gonna have to
gloss over it's like kind of an in depth
topic but it's a really common corporate
finance framework that you'll see
everywhere and the key thing is that
we're trying to take all these cash
flows that are spread out over time and
sort of reframe them for analysis today
and we're gonna do that in a way where
we're adjusting each of those costs for
the risk and the operative those cash
flows for the risk and the opportunity
cost of being in the future and so you
can kind of see that here there's
there's a formula and then you can see
the cash these bar amounts getting
smaller and smaller over time that's not
cuz your cash flows are getting smaller
and smaller over time that's because
there's like this discounting we're
doing this risk adjusting that we're
doing is making them smaller and smaller
over time so that's just a kind of way
to take a bunch of cash flows and
summarize them and one number and with
that with that piece of terminology then
we can define the customer
lifetime value so customer lifetime
value is I'm gonna define it as it's
just the revenue over over the customers
lifetime - all the variable costs
including the cost of goods sold and
then using this net present value
framework to discount and it does not
include customer acquisition costs and
so the whole purpose of this metric is
just to summarize everything that's
contributed by a single customer down to
one number one one single metric and one
thing to highlight is that you may find
inconsistencies in the real world about
the definition of this thing so so we've
excluded customer acquisition cost
some people may include it and the key
point I want to make there is just that
like in general when you talk about
metrics just just define what you're
talking about at the end of the day
maybe the words don't matter but what
matters is that we're all clear on what
we're talking about and and the the key
reason for that is in pursuit of
internal consistency it's like in
general when we want to analyze data and
make some conclusion about let's say
margin we want to make sure that we're
accounting for every component of margin
one and only one time in our analysis
and so naming things helps you get to
that goal of internal consistency so
that is to say whatever whatever you
define if you want to call it Kakkar or
CLV or whatever just define the term
that you're talking about and my second
pro tip is if you want to say I'm cool
don't call it cold because I don't think
anybody that breezy it's it that way so
cool so with that all sort of like in
the background we're gonna start looking
at some real data to do that I have to
talk about where I work I work at second
measure I'm a data scientist there and
head up the data team what we do at
second measure is we analyze billions of
credit card transactions to answer
real-time questions about consumer
behavior these we leverage that our data
to answer questions like this so these
are some examples of things we've done
the one on the left is an analysis we
put together retention in the milk aid
industry
the second one is something that we
looked at about regional variation in
food delivery companies and about how
making certain companies can very
concentrated in vary market in certain
markets and then the last is an
we put together of delete uber and its
effect on retention at lyft and uber we
and as a company we deliver this as a
self-service analytics platform to our
clients so that second measure and so
for reasons there hopefully obvious
we're gonna be analyzing credit card
transaction data and so we're pretty
much going to focus only on the revenue
side of the equation and not on the cost
side and this is not the whole of
business analysis but it's a hugely
important part of it and so everything
that comes from now will just be looking
at revenue so cool so I want to start by
sort of looking at some data where I
picked a company to look at the company
I picked was Dollar General Dollar
General is a chain of variety stores
from that started in Tennessee they
focus on rural areas for the longest
time they had the strategy of building
stores where places like Walmart
wouldn't build stores and have been
pretty successful with that
and fun fact they also owned easy calm
after winning it in a bidding war
against Dolce & Gabana so we're gonna
look at this metric called that I'm
gonna call lifetime spend so I'm gonna
try to do that thing where I define my
metric so lifetime spend will be gross
cumulative sales including taxes we're
not going to be using this discount or
net present value framework and we're
not going to net out any costs and we're
our so our analysis will kind of
generally start with raw data rod it is
gonna is going to look like this so here
every dot is a purchase and we've got
just time on the x-axis and then every
row on the y-axis is a different
customer and we're going to calculate
late lifetime spend by taking all those
customers aligning them by the day of
their first purchase calculating
cumulative spending today over time and
then averaging across all the customers
so that's this is what this kind of
looks like if we do this for a dollar
so you can see that they spend customers
spend twenty twenty dollars to begin
with on average and then over time over
three years it's going to sort of sort
of slowly march up to around two hundred
dollars and when I when I first started
looking at these kind of plots and
looking at Dollar General I didn't
really have great instincts for what
this chart would look like so I looked
it built this and then I said like yeah
okay but the truth is is when you look
at this you probably won't see lines
that look this straight so this actually
kind of gets it what make Dollar General
special special is that they're
remarkably sticky they retain really
well even in the Amazon and Walmart era
and so this sort of like make that clear
we can look at some other companies so
on a top left we got stitch fix so
stitch risk is the subscription close it
clothing box as you can see they have a
much higher lifetime spend than Dollar
General which is which makes sense
stitch fixes pretty far up market from
Dollar General but you also see this
kind of typical curb shape and that
curve is caused by churns so stow it at
a company like stitch fix on day zero
they're gonna have a very large customer
base and then over time those cost of
some of those customers are gonna get
tired with the service and cancel and so
over time there's been they're spending
will kind of decelerate on average
because they spend this event is being
supported by a smaller and smaller
number of customers so that's kind of
you you'll see that in a lot of the data
another examples that I dug off was
Wayfarer Wayfarer is an online furniture
retailer and the interesting thing here
is only that their customers lifetime
spend is very front loaded so you can
see it at $200 initially and then taking
up very slowly from there which is
actually kind of a problem for Wayfarer
so yes so this is this is lifetime spend
$4 general this is kind of one it kind
of what we want to want to reason about
so the question comes like why are we
not done why is this talk not over and
the answer comes with something that I
kind of failed to mention the first time
I walked you through the metric that we
were going to compute which is basically
that anytime we want to align our
customers by that first date and then
average spending were forced to ignore
all the customers we don't have enough
data yet
so all those plots that we were just
looking at we were ignoring all of our
customers that were three years and
younger which is kind of unsatisfying so
that kind of hints at that the key which
is the hard part of analyzing customer
lifetime value which is just the tricky
nature of dealing with partially
observed data so to come back to this
diagram I mean my job is as data
scientist and I think of it as my job to
empower decisions and the truth is you
almost never make decisions in business
with a plot that looks like this most of
the time you're making a decisions based
on the plot that looks like this and so
you've got today and all data passed
today is grayed out you don't know it
and you're forced to make decisions
about what to do about this customer if
you're a marketer or you work in growth
your life is even harder you're actually
going to be reasoning about hypothetical
customers and their hypothetical
customer acquisition cost and then
balancing it against this lifetime value
that you don't know yet so that brings
us to these models which is kind of a
way to deal with this problem our our
approach is going to be fairly simple so
we're going to going back to our raw
data we're going to take all of our
observations all observed data and build
a model on top of them and then we're
going to use that to for all of the data
that comes beyond this black line all
the future data we're gonna use it to
impute so we're gonna we're going to use
that model and fill in essentially
everything past this black line with
expectation values and then we're going
to be able to analyze the data the combo
of those two datasets the real data and
the expected future data together so to
do that so customer purchase data is
fairly multifaceted and so to do this
we're gonna inevitably have to factor
this big problem in two independent sub
problems and so you've got purchase
counts you've got churn you've got
transaction amounts you've got all these
costs and so to start with we're going
to focus almost exclusively on on
purchase counts
and when I when I encounter a problem
like that one thing I like to ask is
what is the simplest thing that could
work and so you know what is the
simplest thing that might work for
events in over time hopefully the answer
is fairly obvious it's a it's a Poisson
process this is kind of like your
classic first assumption that you might
make a Poisson process is just a memory
list process and so you can you can kind
of make this assumption you can fit
Poisson process to customer purchase
data you can look at how well it fits
and the answer is it's a pretty bad fit
um and the reason is kind of hidden
hidden this pictogram so anybody want to
guess what this says I think that's very
close to Poisson aka French fish that
doesn't churn
that's a butter churn yes so so the
Poisson process is just going to keep
going until infinity right whereas
people churn out so so this is just kind
of a fact about our data is that people
will be very engaged with your business
and then one day they'll just disappear
and you know maybe competitor maybe they
got tired with this space whatever it be
whatever it be they're gonna churn and
so we're gonna have to expand their
model and find a way that fits data and
so I'm going to sort of describe one
common approach to doing that and the
way that this is going to work is that
we're gonna make some assumptions about
some latent processes that are on the
unobserved and then we're going to those
those processes are going to add up to
to our observed data and so up top we're
gonna have a Poisson process and that
Poisson process is going to be filtered
through this birth-death process where
we're after this death event all of the
hypothetical purchases are going to be
truncated and our observed data so down
below the line this is what we're going
to see and the term birth death process
here kind of comes from survival
analysis and is just kind of a code name
for this form of assumption where we
there's something that sort of starts
starts the clock
and then after that clock has started
your risk of dying over time or some
event happening over time but that event
can only happen once and so that's kind
of a a fairly familiar set of
assumptions and so we're going to
hybridize this survival process and this
horizontal process to get to our data um
so you can write down a probabilistic
model and you can write down the
likelihood of this observed data given
that those assumptions and then we just
observed I infer back from observed
dated parameters and we're gonna get
back to parameters so the first
parameter we're going to get is the rate
parameter of this process own which is
essentially the expected number of
purchases per unit time conditional on
this person not churning out of the data
and then the second number we're going
to get is this hazard rate is which is
essentially like a probability per unit
time of this person churning and so you
can kind of combine those two estimates
about a customer and you get this this
curve here which is kind of our estimate
that this person has churned conditioned
on the data we observed at the bottom
and so we we know this person was alive
or unearned until their very last
purchased and after that we have two
possible explanations either they're
just taking a break or they've churned
and so this likelihood is gonna gonna
kind of balance those two hypotheses and
go down over time where we become more
and more like more and more certain that
they've turned out so this kind of hits
it at the game plan is how we're going
to factor the problem which is that
we're gonna model transaction count and
churn jointly and then we're gonna deal
with everything else separately and
factor those out so when I first saw
this formulation I was actually a little
skeptical that this whole joint
mechanism was actually necessary so I
kind of want to ask the question again
like is this really the simplest thing
that might work to illustrate that I've
just got some toy data here so this is
just hypothetical purchase data for for
one customer and so this customer has
purchased six different times and those
six purchases happened on three separate
days and you know we can kind of just
compute an average transaction count
over those three observations and get to
and the
what really what we expect for their
going forward purchase rate and I think
the answer is no I kind of intentionally
set this up to be a bad bad approach to
is an overestimate here and the reason
is because we're ignoring the negative
space you know so they they there were
these zeros these days on which this
person didn't purchase and we're
ignoring those in our average and so
we're overestimating the rate and this
may sound like a you know fairly a
fairly simple mistake to make but every
time I go to analyze data I'm gonna make
this mistake so just just caveat emptor
but so so with that in mind
maybe we can sort of fix that bug and
compute a mean where we're not ignoring
these zeros and so the question is is
this one that we get after doing that is
this correct and the answer is a little
more subtle but the answer is that this
is still an overestimate of their
purchase rate and the reason is because
we there's actually a little more
negative space that comes after their
last purchase so their last purchase may
not be the true date on which they
turned out according to the according to
this model and so the amount of negative
space that we're ignoring at the end is
is gonna cause us to like very subtly
bias our estimate and the amount of
negative space that we're ignoring is
going to be very specific to that
customer's purchase rate so it actually
ends up depending on the data and so
this is kind of an illustration that the
the naive approach where you're just
sort of in compute the empirical rate
over their observed purchases will
overestimate the rate and and this this
you know sounds fairly benign but is
really pernicious so so I did a
simulation study to send a sort of
estimate how bad this issue is and I did
it in a setting where I know the true
rate and so I know how bad the bias is
and the answer is it it it you know gets
fairly manageable as long as you're
willing to bucket your data but you need
to Bucky your data to the point where
you've got maybe one or two one or two
events per unit of time that your
bucketing and that'll get you down in
this like 6 to 2% bias or over estimate
rate and that's kind of a deal breaker
for most realistic circumstances so we
analyzed thousands of companies the
second measure and I looked at average
purchase rates and this would mean that
your bucketing your data very coarsely
and you're just getting some very
coarse-grained estimates about customer
lifetime value so yeah that's that
that's kind of the first big idea and
these family of models is that you can
you can build this hybrid likelihood
that is composed from fairly familiar
probabilistic building blocks and the
kind of the name for these models is
that counting your customers models
which is named after the first paper
that was kind of framed in this way so
that's the first big idea
the second bigoted idea that you come
across when you read these papers is
this idea of customer heterogeneity
so I kind of want to describe that a
little bit so to motivate that I want to
I want to actually calculate purchase
rate for for $1 general for our data set
and so we're just going to take take all
of our customers and we're going to
compute the number of purchases and then
we're going to divide by the number of
days that we saw them for and so that
that's here and if we if we plot this
out we're going to get this plot for
dollar general this is each to here is a
different customer and the first thing
to kind of highlight here is that the
variability is extreme so I've had to
plot this on a logarithmic axis for it
to fit and our data is spanning three
full orders of magnitude in that plot
and so this is just kind of a universal
fact is that your customers will spend
like a huge range of activity for your
business you know another way of looking
at that is to go back to this lifetime
value plot so if you're if you're like
me you made this plot and then you
thought about people kind of in orderly
fashion walking up this chart but the
truth is if you if we overlay that all
across the raw data each line here
bringing a different customer it looks
way more disorderly so so there are a
lot of customers who stay very close to
the x-axis and essentially don't
purchase or churn out immediately and
they're being balanced out by a very
small number of high
you customers so that's kind of customer
heterogeneity and in a nutshell but the
second the second thing there that I saw
when I looked at this plot is what are
these weirdos and synthetic striations
on the right right hand side of the data
sets so like our data set looked so nice
and normal and blobby and Gaussian and
then we saw these little ticks here like
what are these like they look alien it's
like this is Elon Musk like what is it
and to go back to the calculation that
we're doing I think the answer becomes
pretty clear if you if we split this
data out by that denominator there um so
if we look at how many days we saw that
person over you can see that for people
who we have a large history we're gonna
very accurately estimate their true
purchase rate whereas for people where
we have very short histories we're just
gonna be looking at pure noise I mean
that noise is but it's both going to be
you know weird-looking and also biased
so so that is kind of customer
heterogeneity as it plays into the hard
part of these models and so these models
have a way of dealing with this which is
- which is multi-level modeling and so I
kind of want to motivate that idea
that's a very generic idea that comes up
in a lot of places multi-level modeling
aka hierarchical models aka random
effects models or mixed effects models
and so just just to describe them
quickly quickly you kind of set up a you
assume an explicit probabilistic plot
process on your observed data so you
talk about a probabilistic a snake
processor is just going to going to lead
to your observations and then because of
that process the models are able to be
aware of the noise level that is going
to be in data like this and and so we're
going to deal with these small sparsely
observed customers by essentially
crafting a prior so in a Bayesian sense
we're going to shrink these estimates
towards a reasonable prior and the
novelty of multi-level models is that
that prior itself is motivated by the
data so we're these models essentially
jointly fit
you know the estimates per customer
along with the prior which is motivated
by this uncorrupted data that we're
seeing up on the top so that's kind of a
key idea in multi-level modeling and I
think of as a as a fairly powerful and
general idea because it allows you to
fit these richly parameter parameterised
models so we're fitting two coefficients
per customer here but still do sensible
things in the area of your data where
you have very few observations so these
models that we've been talking through
there's a very good Python
implementation of them called lifetimes
it's it's it was open source by Shopify
and written by Cameron Davidson P lon
who's a data scientist there and so
Shopify open source this too because
they've been using this internally to
essentially do what we described of
counter your customers and estimating
their lifetime value it implements a
family of models so these are all the
counting your customers models but
there's a couple of them and if I can
just kind of be opinionated just pick
the bottom one so this is called the
modified beta geometric negative
binomial distribution model or MBG NBD
which is just named from from the
parametric assumptions that we're taking
on those probabilistic processes and
each model is going to have a very
slightly different story about the sort
of data generating process story about
how the data is generated but um but
they all have a very similar flavor so
this is just the MGP NBD model
protip nobody calls it the model but you
know yeah so uh so yeah so next up I
wanted to sort of illustrate how you can
use that use those models to do that
we're gonna have to look at a new
company so I picked bird so birds a
little more exciting the Dollar General
they're a scooter startup the scooter
share startup as you're aware out of
Santa Monica so we can kind of start by
making this lifetime spend chart for
bird this is what it looks like but this
is really unsatisfying so we can only do
100
eighty days because we have such a short
history for bird and to do that hundred
and eighty days I had to throw out 80%
of their customers and that's because
bird is growing like a rocket so that's
that's really unsatisfying we can kind
of band-aid that a little bit by going
to cohorts so this is what we would do
if we just grouped all the data by
grouped all the customers by the date of
their first purchase and then had one of
these lines for each of those cohorts
but and I like these I like these plots
but they're also really hard to read and
very dangerous to show people because
they all make conclusions on their own
so so so basically what we want to do is
find some way to summarize this data and
say something about birds the value of a
customer at bird also to illustrate this
heterogeneity point I actually did that
but I did that for the three regions
that that bird is operating in so they
grew very early on in the West but then
later on exploded in the south as well
and so if we were trying to analyze and
compare the south and the west we would
we would run against the problem that
this is a very different mix of customer
vintages so the average customer in the
West is a lot older than the custom
average customer in the south so we have
more data on them so these modern models
are essentially a way to analyze while
controlling for that that known
difference so we can start by making
this plot this cohorted plot split by
region you can clearly see that lifetime
value in the south is going to be lower
than than in the west but you can't
really read it from the chart and so to
do this we we can simply fit one of
these models use these models to to fit
and you sort of uncorrupted estimate for
every customer and then you use those
estimates to project out whatever you
want in this case I've projected out 24
months sales 30 20 for my four month
total sales for for bird and we got a
16% lower light lower 24 month value for
the south region than for the west so
for bird the takeaway is just the
customers act differently and you can't
assume that new markets behave the same
as proven ones which is kind of another
another instance of this customer
heterogeneity phenomenon
so yeah coming back to these models like
it all to me it all comes back to like
why do we care about this chart and the
reason to me is because I think this
chart is central to tons of
decision-making in business so it all
reasons around like deciding what is
gonna happen estimating what is going to
happen to a group of customers finding
customers that are expected to end up
above the y-axis hopefully well above
the y-axis and then operating your
business in such a way that it stays
there over time so coming back to the
ideas that we we talk through so the
first one is just that this this
workflow where you build models from
your observed data and use it to project
the future and then kind of analyze the
combo of the two it is fairly powerful
in my opinion and the second one is that
probabilistic models can be a good way
to tell a story about your data and then
fit fit models to that data the third
one is that heterogeneity bounds and and
as a result you have to kind of mind the
noise in your data and the fourth one is
just to pleat it define your metrics
when you use them if you're interested
in learning more these are some views
and references so on we talked a little
bit of corporate finance and I'm a huge
fan of a swath of motor Inns lectures
he's a professor at NYU Stern and puts
all of his lectures up online if you're
interested in multi-level modeling so
this is a great book if you're
interested in these models check out
life times and check out the blog that
Shopify put out and then we talked
briefly about survival analysis and I
just want to plug a talk from some
former co-workers about that yeah so
that's it thanks so much I hope this was
a this was kind of helpful in sparking
some ideals that you get to use in your
work and I work at second measure and
we're hiring as you can read here but
that was pretty much it thanks yeah
who had presumably a team trying to
optimize their sales
how are you ensuring that you're not
modeling on their kind of outlier
effects there yeah yeah they're their
outlier effects so I mean that is a good
question so we I mean our goal in that
second measure is essentially to you
know characterize what's going on on the
ground and so you know at the end of the
day I think we would we would think
about the effects that we observe as
being real in the sense that this is
actual cash flow to the business but we
could definitely be observing what's
going on on their growth team but and to
sort of know the impacts of what's going
on on their growth team we have to be
able to essentially estimate whether the
customers that they've acquired are
gonna have the same you know same value
that all the other customers are but if
we can estimate that then those effects
are real those effects will propagate
through the business which is what we
care about making conclusions about does
that help ya know for instance when
you're trying to get new customers back
in years
I feel like so I've ever done media mix
modeling which is hierarchical modeling
and not that world that you're trying to
optimize your ad spend using data where
you don't necessarily know it's like
Home Depot was having a product and so
you have to kind of figure out a way to
make sure that you're not capturing
those yeah yeah yes so I think we you
know generally we're gonna try and help
with breaking your data into subgroups
and analyzing value amongst our group
subgroups but assessing causality within
those subgroups is a very tricky
question so and I think that's what
you're getting at is I don't know that
there are good solutions to that other
than to be defensive and careful are
other questions
you you were using the West good for
work usually West Coast ask me those
other ones we were you know so the
approach that I took there was to to
essentially fit separate models on the
west and on the south so so completely
on unpooled data so the West will have
one model and one estimate in the south
of another model another another
estimate you can also think of these as
being covariates or features and see you
can sort of extend the model so that it
has covariates in there but here i just
sort of like split that split the data
set that make sense
how uh looking at the different regions
so how would you account for these no
facts like I'm from the Midwest like
family sure sure
well I do wonder about that for bird
like I think we don't have enough data
to see how it's gonna play out in like
really cold regions but um you know
they're just there is that you know
these these models are essentially or
the the frame point you're gonna the
perspective you're gonna take when
you're analyzing them data this way is
that you have some growth that's kind of
an input or something that you would
forecast that is gonna be highly
seasonal and you're gonna have to know
about that that seasonality and then
these models care a lot about the
retention and so they care a lot about
sort of like whether there are seasonal
effects and retention and you know on
the ground you will observe seasonality
and retention it's usually a lot more
muted than then then acquisition for
example custody but but I think maybe
for a very weather based startup like
bird it might be seasonal and we'll have
to look at that and then if you wanted
to account for that in these models you
would have to kind of do that covariant
extensions you would have to have like
that that probability of churning being
able to depend on the season of the year
essentially caught maybe one more
[Music]
you know just anyway
I mean my start as criticism
I mean II like pay off ever again
yeah
sure sure so yeah and and just to be
clear we're modifying we're modeling
their their purchase events like the
times of those events are the frequency
of those events is plus on and then we
essentially need a separate model to
estimate the purchase amount conditional
on purchasing you know and so I didn't
really get into that here but there's
like model that's common in the same
literature called the gamma gamma model
which is yeah a uniform assumption a
krav purchase amounts and I think yet
the I think in reality for for cases
where you really want accurate accurate
sort of estimates you um you do want to
essentially essentially go to a more
complex model or a model that has like
the ability to tie those two together
but part of the part of the message here
is that this is a very multifaceted
problem and you do have to kind of like
assume independence somewhere and so
this is one of the places that's they
kind of do assume independence to make
the to make the problem like not one
giant joint estimation problem
[Music]